nicolas guiet rebond je vous remercie
d'être en direct sur arte france ce
matin alors il n'y a pas eu d'annoncé
officielle de la part du ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer
mais les établissements scolaires ont
reçu ce nouveau protocole sanitaire est
ce que vous regrettez cette méthode tout
d'abord complètement le gouvernement est
inconséquent et incohérent on a quand
même le virus qui repart partout et pas
seulement en france d'ailleurs dans
toute l'europe des mesures sont prises
par exemple l'italie pour la rentrée a
décidé de créer 80 4 nuls poste et ça
coûte 1 milliards aux contribuables
italiens donc fait ce choix là nous
qu'est ce qu'on fait au mieux la réalité
le virus repart par tour mais on oblige
à remettre le masque compris dans la rue
dont énormément de communes le virus
circule
il nous explique que tout va être
tranquille où on allège les mesures
notamment à l'université ain où ce sont
de jeunes adultes qui clairement son
contenant et autres en maternelle et en
primaire ou non relève le masque alors
que les enfants ne savent pas respecté
les gestes barrières et qu'ils sont
contaminants et qu'ils sont contaminés
il ya une grande inconséquence
gouvernement est complètement incohérent
comment justement comptez vous appliquer
ces nouvelles règles dans d'autres
classes vous l'avez dire le port du
masque pour les enseignants mais
également
la distanciation physiques ne sont plus
obligatoires sauf cela est possible
effectivement le seul moyen pour
préserver compris virus les est
marinière max des classes peut être plus
allégée mais pour ça il faut investir
or dans le plan de relance l'éducation
est complètement milliers comme
d'habitude nous demandent depuis un an
et demi maintenant 40 points comme
d'impression qui construit parce qu'on a
perdu de son côté 1 3 de pouvoir d'achat
des français à l'ère rattrapage rien au
niveau des moyens régnant au niveau du
respect que vous êtes urinant on a même
une réponse est en train d'avoir lieu
dans l'académie de poitiers
la rectrice de poètes les s'acharne sur
des collègues ne fasse le fonds mondial
c'est elle qui a produit des bases de
respect de petits badges virtuels pour
récompenser les profs ont mis de salaire
donc en plus d'être insultant et
humiliant c'est stupide
on sent bien votre colère pendant le
confinement il eu voilà plusieurs
actions vous avez dénoncé justement les
méthodes du gouvernement qui n'ont pas
pris leurs responsabilités concernant
les élèves est ce que vous prévoyez des
actions des manifestations à la rentrée
pour dénoncer ce nouveau protocole
sanitaire que vous rejetez tout à fait
nous allons être présents nous n'allons
pas entendre il n'y a aucune chance que
jean michel bongard ce patron qui est
notre but n'est pas de l'embêter antoine
autres d'être entendue puisque le seul
moyen d'être entendu et de l'embêter
nous allons l'embêter il faut rajouter à
ça une chose dont la répression
j'ajoute le prg est longue et
contractuel c'est à dire les gens qui se
font embaucher pour faire deux trous
dans l'éducation nationale
sachez quand même que par une vague de
licenciements massifs aux médias nous
ont été massivement ou devient
maltraités soutenait alors cadeau de
vacances et on va les ré embauche
tenable
on verra donc des enseignants au
primaire et au collège donc c'est un
traitement un bout il le resterait on me
demande mon exige n'aurait secrètes les
personnels correctement et sofuoglu mois
commente on sent alors on sent bien que
la rentrée scolaire 2020 risque d'être
délicate avec ce protocole sanitaire
alléger
mais également avec beaucoup d'élèves
qui finalement n'ont pas eu classe
pendant plus de deux mois qui se
retrouvent en difficulté aujourd'hui
comment est ce que vous allez pouvoir
rattraper tous les cours perdus à la
rentrée alors les cours n'ont pas été
totalement perdu on vous l'a travaillé
on a beau temps continue l'éducation
nationale n'était pas en vacances mis en
chômage partiel aux contrats de beaucoup
d'autres métiers je ne critique pas si
loin que ça eu lieu et ce n'est pas le
cas de l'éducation nationale donc on a
continué à faire faut effectivement il
ya des élèves qui auraient pu mal
sportivement il ya même eu des bons
sinon c'est pas grâce une assiette comme
on a pu à la rentrée on va mettre le
paquet
on va voir comment ça se passe déjà où
on est le virus et si le gouvernement
réalise un petit peu à ce lieu d'être
dans l'idéologie media.fr tout va bien
et on va mettre le paquet l amour dont
alors aux primaires en français et en
maths et tu devrais essayer de voir quel
délai ce qu'on récupère de l'année
patrice moi je vais vraiment un
événement programmé de l'antique al
savoir qu'elle soit reconnaissance qui
n'ont pas pu voir on demande aux parents
il faut surveiller que les enfants
apprennent bien lors le second travaille
bien la maison et par an seront
nécessaires
merci beaucoup nicolas glières d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes enseignant et membre des
stylos motion